today's episode it was taped live at the
Durango Casino and Resort over in Las
Vegas Nevada and we are grateful to them
for letting us spend time at their
beautiful uh place for gambling and fun
and joy if you like it you will like it
that's Durango Casino and Resort thank
you for letting us tape your episode our
episode over there today's guest is the
current middleweight champion of the UFC
uh he grew up in uh one of the rougher
areas is of Southern
California um he is a complex
individual that's for damn sure he's a
damn he's a dang 30-sided Rubik's cube
of a human uh but he's an undeniable
talent in the world of fighting um
there's something just there's something
extremely lovable about the guy uh and
he's and he's not afraid to speak his
mind now how how good is his mind with
that's that's TBD uh but but I'm very
thankful for his time and um and it was
a joy to sit down with him today's guest
is Mr sea
stri shine that light on
[Music]
me I'll sit and tell you my
stor
shine on
me and I will find a song I been
singing
all right I'm ready guys we ready yeah
we're ready get the dick get the dick
wet yeah huh well I don't I mean got to
pay for it you know there's a lot of
other terms we could use yeah I guess
that's one way to do
it um yeah a lot of so for people that
don't know you're the middleweight
champion of the world right yeah [__]
weird right man yeah the UFC's really
lowered their standards
youed should be class and they let my
ass in here you know [__] hey how's
your latte good it's okay man I just
needed something I don't do drugs or
alcohol so not anymore yeah yeah that's
good dude good call yeah and it's so
then it's slim pickings on what do you
use to get you going you know yeah or
something like that smelling we all got
we all got an addiction you know we all
got an addiction mine's you know
caffeine are you is it really oh I
[__] crush it dude I [__] crush it
oh wow how much can you have in one day
you think oh D I have like 10 cups Cofe
in to day especially when I'm dieting I
just drink that [__] instead of food
really yeah and do you still have the
ability to eat or to use your hands well
after that ideally I'd try not to eat
yeah but yeah no man this is you're
doing big [__] things dude you went
from a white trash [__] redneck to
interviewing Tucker [__] Carl and do
them big things dude big [__] things
dude I can't believe they would let
either one of us really have a job H man
dude he you know what's weird about you
dude and let me say one thing and this
is like honest to God truth like
sometimes did you say some genius [__]
like you say some [__] where like I'm
like [__] I scratched my head and
sometimes you say some [__] where I'm
like this man's
[__] so I hav been quite figured out
dude if you're a genius a little bit of
Bull made a little bit of Rainman in you
you know thanks man yeah yeah I don't
know yeah I know yeah look I think it's
like um I think sometimes it's hard for
me to match up my thoughts and my words
at the same time you know so I think
sometimes it's like there's like a uh if
I really think about it um I think
there's sometimes it's like my I can't
tell if my brain starts going before my
mouth does or one or the other you know
but I feel like some of the equivalency
or whatever isn't uh like the gear
shafts off or whatever you know or the
like my I don't know yeah because you
guys before I started this he was saying
some clever [__] dude talking about all
the [__] paid for like but it was going
really [__] good well I wouldn't say
I PID yeah I would say yeah have you
ever paid for [__] I don't know you
don't know how do you not it's a very
simple question dude have you ever took
out your wallet and said here's 20 bucks
blow me oh no nothing like that brother
dude I'll tell you this one time I went
to Vietnam right and so uh I was a
student right and we went there on you
were a student you went to school oh
yeah no [__] what' you
study urban planning dude no [__] you're
a college man huh uh yeah I'm an urban
planner did you
graduate yeah oh here do I here I am
thinking we're Cut From the Same Cloth
this man's an educated man I wouldn't
say educated I mean yeah I have yeah I
mean I have like Microsoft Word or
whatever on my computer we go but I
wouldn't say yeah I all right dude you
know I say you're in Vietnam [__]
later boys well tell me about it no no
well I got there and whenever we got
there you can tell the taxi drivers or
whatever to take you anywhere right and
they will literally take you to a whouse
yeah You' be like anyway like take us to
the hospital my friend is bleeding to
death and they'll drop you both off at
you know and they'll try to like you
know and your friend can barely get an
erection because his pulse is low or
whatever you know because of his uh you
know his heart rate or whatever puss
[__] will cure a lot of issues yeah
like I can't tell you how many times
I've been really [__] up and you get
some good [__] you're like you know I
guess it's not broken we'll be all right
we go to hospital tomorrow yeah we'll do
this [__] tomorrow it is true oh the
touch of a woman I think has always done
that done that for men you know I didn't
to me dude like real talk I can't pay
for [__] dude I went to the Philippines
yeah I can't either yeah like I don't
know why like if a girl don't want to
[__] me I don't want to [__] mind you
guys I got a girlfriend I'm doing the
right things I'm doing the right things
I don't cheat on my chick but you know
back in the day back in the day
if a girl don't want to [__] with me I
generally don't want to do it you know
yeah yeah yeah I didn't like I mean I
would get well I if I ever paid for
women I would um if I ever paid for no
You' definitely paid for [__] bro I
don't know I I mean and this could also
be but there's nothing right there's
nothing wrong with that bro I mean you
know you you're helping the economy
you're [__] you're you're you're
paying for a service yeah yeah you're
right I think that it's definitely and
they used to do it like on the Mayflower
and everything but I'll tell you this
dude I would I would be high on drugs
and then I would hire an escort are can
you hear us okay
yeah yeah I got you I'll put it I'll put
it by I generally don't I get a little
like [__] put big black really
[__] scary dude you know maybe you
made it more of a b Nick or not should
we put it somewhere else okay no we're
good dude um cuz he looks caged up over
there does he I feel really no well
we're in this [__] prostitute room
yeah yeah I mean it's nice way you got
women on the brain today huh [__]
[__] all I got is testosterone bro
what do you think that's all yeah all I
want to do is [__] kill a man and you
know [__] a woman but I got a girlfriend
I'll cheat on her so you know yeah yeah
sure dude you said that so many times me
me and her me and her are wondering but
here's the thing here's the thing the
moment I stop saying it I'm going to put
my dick in anything in the moves I just
got to like make that positive
affirmation I'm not going to do I'm not
going to do it I'm not going to do
it I'm not going to move then um dude
well but but here's what would happen I
would do drugs I would hire an escort
right yeah that's fair they would come
over I'd be so high and scared paranoid
that there was like a guy with a gun or
a pimp and a lot of times the S it
wouldn't be the same person in the
pictures I would um go downstairs I
would give the money to them and have
them leave and I would be too scared to
um and also I'd be so high on drugs I
couldn't like even get my wiener going
and something and so yeah you'd be so
scared cuz the CRA e thing is inviting
somebody over your house to have sex and
you can't have sex then you're just you
know just like you just got to talk to
them well then you're just Milling
around for a while you know for an hour
or something what do you what do you
when you talk to a hooker what do you
say like hey how's your day like just
ask them where they're from or whatever
where you from how'd you get here yeah
yeah what yeah what else what else do
you any good stories from them like what
do do you have any hobbies I guess I
don't know if that's a crazy but yeah
dude I would get you suck today that's
FID I mean we never wonder that I've
always I've always wondered like okay
you get a hooker and say you're like the
last client of the night okay like yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
[__] seen to get through you know
what I'm saying like like you ever but
like you ever wonder that like what what
number of my what what tag did I get
yeah I think you wonder where yeah how
you yeah I guess what you're going to
yeah I guess you where you can be for
the lady or whatever yeah I think yeah
you don't want to like if a lady comes
and she's got she's seem like she's been
sweating and stuff it's like at that
point I think you just kind of Coach
them up you know you're almost more of a
you take examine do you look for like
any razor burn
before like dude I'm telling you I would
be so high I would literally go
downstairs crack the door because I'd be
so scared that they would have a um like
a pimp Orab yeah like an officient or
whatever you know or or a commander or
whatever they I don't know what a lot of
hookers have but it's like and then I
would put the money outside of the door
give it to them and then kind of go like
that or whatever and uh and that doesn't
mean they're Asian or whatever but I
would just like do like that and and
then um then this would be the craziest
part though I would still be texting
them like did you get home okay that
would be the craziest [__] and they're
like leave me the [__] alone you know
well you're a lover bro you're a nice
guy I don't know if I mean I think uh I
the whole thing just scared me man but I
always if I would yeah like women have
always had like that's you know it's had
a big effect on me I mean how do you get
laid now you must be hard right like to
get laid now like you just can't go [__]
the average woman like how do you how do
you get your dick wet now well I mean
it's hard right like you're you're a
[__] famous guy dude yeah yeah I
don't I mean I guess I I mean let me say
it's easy but it's easy but then it's
also like you know I think you get
scared that girls are trying to like
like like I think you not use you for
like I think I get scared that I don't
want to communicate with girls like or
something ask them show your [__] and
the theovon ask me to show my [__] I
wouldn't use that I would use like some
charades or something or you know like
maybe do like a um send like two gifts
you know one is like a curtain open like
that and then a picture of a cat is the
second one okay just to lead them on a
little bit Yeah Yeah but I wouldn't say
like let me you know you have to do a
lot of you ever s you ever sent pictures
of your dick never not a snapchatter
I've sent a picture of my buddy Jason's
dick that my buddy Jason used to for
like this is a few years back but I'm
sure he would still let us use it or I
don't know if like you can use it more
than once but for 10 bucks he'd let you
send his [__] to a gal was it a good
looking dick was it big it was [__]
it was what it was it was like one of
those kind of unique mushrooms I feel
like you ever had that chicken where
they put those weird looking mushrooms
kind of with it oh yeah no I got you
like that rich Place chicken or
something rich Place chicken that gravy
and that weird mushroom do you know man
I have like I have a weird opinion of
looking at Dicks like here's the thing
dude yeah what let's just say we're in a
UR what is the thing because we haven't
started yeah let's just say you're the
UR you're in a urinal right now right
and you're standing next to me and you
pull your dick out I'm GNA look I'm
going to look at your dick uhuh I'm not
gay but it's like you know me and you're
pissing next to each other I might look
at your dick just to see what the's
working with I'm curious yeah but you
know what annoys me like you'll be in a
locker room change with the boys right
and like you're naked and you'll get
some people like they don't want to look
at the dick they don't want to look at
your or they look away they're like
they're offended by your dick and I'm
like dude I'm like I take it as a
personal insult if you don't want to
look at my dick and I'll tell you why
I'll tell you I'll tell you why dude
I'll tell you why you will sit there in
the [__] we hours of the night middle
of night just beating your little
[__] dick off all night long to big
dicks all different colors the dicks all
the dicks right on the inter on thewe
and like so you're sitting there beating
your dick off and then you come time to
look at my dick and you're like you're
offended by my dick like [__] you dude
you're a [__] at the end of the day
like I mean if it yeah I don't yeah I
don't I mean I like that's closet
homosexuality like if you can't look at
my dick without like feeling shame maybe
you're gay and ain't nothing wrong being
gay dude ain't nothing wrong with it I
don't yeah I would look I don't I mean
look and we might who one of us could be
gay who knows anything gay anything gay
you ever well hold on I want to I want
to think about this I think if you look
at a guy's wiener and I'm just going to
um say you look at a guy's uh Wier and
then if you open your like if like your
first reaction I think is if your mouth
opens I'm just trying to think of what
are some signals that a dude might have
some homosexuality in him and then I
don't think yeah I think you're kind of
right man I think a guy should be able
to say look at that's my dick that's my
dick dude and I'll I'll compliment a
dick dude I'll compliment a dick nice
dick Randy yeah no there's a yeah there
wow buddy H there's this guy named Carl
big UFC guy big black guy big African
big African man right oh yeah so he's
wearing sing a single you know single oh
yeah no cup dude no cup and he has this
big old [__] big old black dick and I
I say black dick as opposed to a normal
colored dick because I feel like a black
dick like it's a little bit more like
you know long and this man's wearing a
Singler and his dick is like I mean it
was like here and then he's like hey
Sean let me show you something and he
like gets against the wall and he
spreads his legs he's like come put your
head right here in a single leg I'm like
Carl
like like dude I I I think you got a
good looking dick I think it's big I
think it's girthy you know I think you
could pregnant a lot of women with that
dick yeah but I'm not going to put my
hair on your dick and he and what did
y'all do and I said no I'm not going to
do it and then I'm like and I said but
hey he'll do it another guy came put his
head on his dick [__] it's I'll use a
thing to roll out my legs you ever use
those leg rollers oh that's what it felt
like that's what it felt like I feel
like that would be like to I mean here
saying there's a lot of large Blackman
MMA so it's like you know you're in the
locker room and you're just like oh we
had have a guy this dude I've told this
story but he at our school and he would
come and pee right over your back when
we were kids right into the pisser dude
this dude Mr Larry he was at our
elementary school for so long at a
certain point they just make you a
janitor right and uh yeah he'd come
right in and just piss right over your
back um but yeah I guess you know what
there should be a different uh attit
yeah cuz it is such a thing where you're
just like talking to people in the
locker room but you're like talking at
weird angles and and also don't want to
look a dude in the now it's weird to
look a guy in the eye that's naked I
think and also cuz there's both an
energy that you both know you can't look
at the guys I don't have that energy I
don't have that energy if you got a big
dick you know I I I don't got a big dick
you know I mean my dick I would say it's
it's average little bit it's a little
bit thick I got a thicker penis I'm not
going to say it's like that's fine extra
long but it's like it's thick you know
yeah least that's what they say to make
me feel better I don't know I but I def
I definitely got the big ones hurt
speech yeah yeah no not but not for me
yeah you got the good siiz dick the big
one's HT have you got that speech uh I
don't know if I've gotten that I'm have
to look to I mean but you're wearing
these little spandex I can see the
little the dick outline you know you oh
I was bro I I I definitely I'm I I I was
doing masturbation yesterday so my penis
is how old when you first started
drinking off H let me think for a
second not that old well well not that
old bro give mean like a time frame oh
my bad uh probably maybe 13 I remember I
found some uh that's an old age start
ding off dude is it yeah really I mean I
I was like telling the Rogan about this
man you know like by the way Rogan
wasn't cool what you said about me I'm a
[__] nice guy from last night yeah it
wasn't cool I'm I'm gonna bring up with
the Rogan okay but like we had a
communal porn box you know like you had
siblings you Brothers no like my my
house bro like my dad had one you know
oh yeah I used to bike across town to go
use my buddy's Dad porn me I'm 43 oh
dude but you had the hard living like
kids these days man like how do you not
like how do you like you just pick up
your [__] cell phone and type in
PornHub bro like how do you not I know
yeah if I were a child I could not
probably oh I'd have a problem dude oh
I'd be that hammer all day I guess kids
these days aren't [__] yeah well
there's a lot of rumors you hear you
know and you can't ask them hey are you
[__] because you're an adult you know
that's a weird part say you just pretend
that I guess you just unless you're an
MMA Coach man a lot a lot of coaches
start [__] their shoot but no like no
this is a this is fact dude uh kids
these days D they ain't [__] anymore
they're [__] weak dude they're just
weak men but do you think that that but
why is there a correlation you think
between or like a connection between
weak and not [__] you think well
here's the thing man yeah here's the
thing I think that this tasan level of
man is like vastly decreasing but I
think it's just kind of like I think
it's what they want bro I think it's
like what the system wants they want you
to be a weak man if you're a weak man
you don't want to [__]
well they want you to be I mean if you
look at China right China is they don't
like you ever been to China no when you
go I don't think I could go dude I talk
way too much down China winning the PO
[__] yeah oh yeah [__] yeah oh China
they don't they don't I but the the
people there they don't even seem and I
don't mean this to be offensive they
seem like
uh like Bots like they don't even like
they all like it just seems like a
they're just working and they're it
doesn't seem like there's any real life
let me say I always say if I had life in
prison and I was going to [__] a dude
I'd rather be a China man really they're
soft bro they're soft people are they
delicate they haired you know you
they're delicate they're hairless yeah
you know they make good lady boys yeah I
mean like that's a situation where I'd
be like all right well I want to be
Sarah shell with a lady boy China man
but you know but I mean it just dude the
world's getting [__] soft dude okay
all right well let's let me think about
it so the world's getting soft okay
we'll talk about last night okay right
you get this [__]
krius and like we live in this world now
where people just could say whatever the
[__] they want and I don't think that
helps people get like hard right so it's
like I could go online right now I go on
the interwebs and I could start telling
you go [__] yourself [__] your mother
[__] your girlfriend [__] you and any
kind of recourse that you
do you'll go you'll get in trouble for
like right now I mean you don't got a
girlfriend or anything right like just
you got a girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend but I met your girlfriend at
the slap fight yeah sweet girl right but
they just say right now you had a
girlfriend or someone you loved I can
get up right now be like hey you know
you know blah blah blah she's a [__]
this and that and you technically can't
do anything to me and if you do
something to me you will go to prison
right like how do you that's interesting
but like dude we we didn't we weren't
always like that oh that used to be the
case oh [__] if you said something you
had if Twitter was in real life you'd
[__] die and but you were celebrated
I mean you know take Andrew Jackson for
instance one of the greatest presents we
ever had you know he had some weird [__]
with the Indians but we don't different
time you guys different [__] time but
you know this man killed a man because
he implied his wife was a [__] just the
pure implication of your wife is a [__]
he killed this man one of the one of the
greatest men of our [__] time and now
it's like you know the government is
like slowly just took the nuts away from
men you know like even like so yeah I
agree with you man I think it's like L
when's the last time that you got like
push to a point to where you're like I'd
like to [__] this man up do you remember
that off top of your head yeah tell us
one the last time probably one month ago
maybe what happened
[Music]
uh oh I had yeah somebody that just that
I was working with that just [__]
something up so bad you know and I was
like you know
what I would like to abuse this guy like
to abuse him a little bit yeah yeah yeah
so you know a little different but I'm
saying like so you take drus you know we
get in this like we get in this [__]
heated fight you know e heated press
conference he starts talking about like
child abuse and like yeah you know your
dad [__] you like again you
guys dad didn't [__] me that didn't
never [__] happen you guys you know I
mean we all have some bad memories but
we just all can we chalk him up as bad
dreams and we just move on from there
you know yeah or yeah but yeah if he
didn't but you know but it regardless of
the fact it's like so then I get put in
the spot where like you have this man
next to me so it's like he he's able to
speak to me in a
way that in all of human all of human
history not even just America you would
never speak to a [__] man that way
you would never [__] do it but what
we have done dude we have made people so
pathetic that we just sit there and say
yeah say whatever you want say whatever
you want I'm just going to [__] take
it I'm just going to take it like [__]
it dude like America is one of the
softest [__] in the world well
a lot of it I think you so then I think
you're probably talking about like civil
like everything has become a lawsuit
you're going to get [__] sued you're
going to go to jail you know yeah like
when I was a kid I know that if you said
something that was [__] up somebody
would [__] you up you know like here's
how you knew you couldn't say the n-word
because you would say it and then you
get [__] up yeah you get [__] up
there wasn't like some big system online
that would judge you whatever you knew
now if you had a mixed buddy he might
let you slip it in after midnight or
something but if you were just a you
know you know every now and then there
might be a phrase that you say like oh
[__] my bad yeah like hey let me you
knowy look give me a I need to pass on
that one yeah hey man it's leap here let
me get one in you know but like so I'm
I'm at this press conference with [__]
right and he's like talking about like
child mestation child abuse I saw it
yeah like and here I am dude like now if
now I'm in this weird position where I
can't defend myself because say like say
I'm like hey [__] you man like my dad
never [__] me but I'm going to come
put my if I if I would have followed up
with it now what am I doing I I'm pretty
much saying that like what you said by
joking about like being abused or
molested like you I'm somehow a weaker
man for that the fact that that again
didn't happen to me but if it did happen
to me I'm a weaker man so by me being a
defensive and like clapping back and
going back now it's
like there's some things that were off
limits you know you don't really talk
about a man's wife yeah you don't really
you know you don't talk about a man's
wife you don't talk about a man's kids
and you don't talk about like [__] a
kid being abused these things were all
off limits and dude like once he crossed
that it was like and so was that the
energy that was there whenever you guys
were in
this I tried to ignore it I tried to
[__] ignore it D were you sitting
there thinking throughout the evening a
little bit like oh yeah I was I was
boiling dude I was just I just told
myself like hey just I [__] hate that
boy I hatey yeah I just I'm just saying
there like you see I'm just seeing that
I'm just ignore it just [__] ignore
it and he just St talking [__] I'm like
all right [__] this guy but when you say
ignore was there already that voice some
of that REM oh yeah you have voice in
your head like kill this man and this is
what like this is what people don't
understand like that's a crazy voice I'm
not just saying oh D I've like dude I
have like I don't know if it's like I
have that voice dude yeah like oh it's
bad I mean I'll go like 120 and a
[__] 30 mile per hour like I I have
that voice is such an extreme yeah but
you know it's like it annoys but if it
didn't even happen why did it hurt you
so much though I think it was just the
ability that he can say that people can
say the fact that you can say that with
impunity and then it's kind of a weird
situation man cuz like I got a I got a
big deep fan base and like we all we all
got [__] up as you know we've all gone
most of us have gone through [__] right
I mean I could tell you how many guys do
I know that've been molested as I mean I
know a lot oh yeah I know a lot of
[__] a lot of men who've been
molested I know more women who talk
about it but I know a lot of guys and
like you know my you know 2 am hits are
just bullshitting with like hey man Sean
like what I was this age just happen
like [__] dude I know now my bad dude so
to have this [__] [__] like
make a joke about that yeah but you know
but this is the issue dude man like back
in the day
like there were some repercussions there
there still would be there would still
be if draus like again like and maybe
just generally touched the nerve that
it's like it's like just about like kids
being abused that kind of [__] I feel
you dude there's some things that people
could say but there's so many like dude
how I mean you're 40 how many more years
you got left on this L Earth probably
probably 30 36 I mean 30 if you're lucky
dude I mean you know what I'm saying
dude I'm [__] doing I'm [__] doing
pretty good I got a low blood pressure
or whatever but other than that I'm
[__] doing good I mean you never know
D okay let just say let just say even
20 20 25 25 all right give me 25 all
right give me at least 22 dude I mean so
in the day like say I'm going die at 60
D all everybody in my family dies young
right so I got like 30 years I got like
30 years and you're motorcycle too don't
you oh yeah I go hard too oh yeah dude I
go hard bro you guys are the organ
donors usually yeah for sure dude oh
yeah I woke up I mean look you shall
[__] up my knees through my jeans yeah
but uh yeah so anyways it's like I mean
I got 30 years left what does that mean
what does that mean to me I got to wake
up every day and and go fight and cut
Wade and eat a [__] cheeseburger like
in the grand scheme of things you like
life is not that
important right well so what I agree I
think when you die like you're just like
all you care about all the only things
you feel about like even like even from
like using DMT and stuff you have that
moment of what it feels like when you
die and you don't remember any of life
all you remember is the religious man do
you think you're going to go somewhere
and you die I believe that you go back
into the Universe I think the Lord could
be over there I think um G you know I
think I'm sure Jesus and some of the
other deities are Milling around you
know I'm sure they're in the locker room
kind of like oh we got to get back out
there Sunday's coming up JC it's get out
yeah see I don't I don't I think dude I
think whenever that [__] whenever
that brain goes off you just darkness
bro just darkness no man you evaporate
into something really [__] beautiful
but I think the only feeling is just
sheer Joy but I'm okay with that like
I'm okay so I think in what you do in in
life matters but yeah I mean you could
spend it how you want right now life is
good I got money I got a belt dude
everything is good but like you could
pay me to go [__] relive my life like
you said hey Sean you want to go hit the
restart butt and like [__] you really
[__] no but what if you got to a place
one day where you were able to like like
be because at a certain point I think
like people from a tough environment
become Inspirations for people from a
tough environment you know oh yeah no I
mean I I get guys like will call me
crying yeah I mean I've heard some of
the [__] you've got man you get some
crazy [__] too dude yeah yeah we get
some guys that have been through a lot
of stuff dude and the guys that are
perverts everything we parents together
uh my dad was real old my dad was like
70 and rough it was just weird man I was
just so I was embarrassed you know but
uh but yeah we were just when you so
mean your dad died like when he died my
mom was just worked and my mom didn't
like mom remarried yeah she married a
guy he used to own a car wash that was
pretty cool he always had that he always
had a bunch of change on him no [__]
yeah and we go [__] get all the
change that's nice when your mom when
your Mom married I D I always knew Mom
I'm sorry for this but you know it's
funny I always knew the kind of guy my
mom was hooking up with with the kind of
music she'd be listening to so you'd get
some like You' get some like I'm not
even joking bro yeah You' get some like
R&B or some [__] you know next thing you
know bro there's a black guy hanging
around hey
you get some you get some like salsa
music and you got wand down the street
like how the [__] yeah dude yeah so
[__] ay man did your mom date a lot
then I mean she was
married so I guess yeah she did date a
lot well how does that even make sense
this episode is sponsored by prize piics
now do you love firing on Sports well
prize picks is the best daily fantasy
sports app for you that's correct you
can fire on all your favorite sports
like the NBA NFL UFC and many more what
I like about prize pick is that it's
Innovative instead of choosing teams you
choose individual players each player
has a set projection and you just choose
more or less than that set projection so
it's pretty Innovative really um like if
you want to say that uh Victor um one uh
win win banan is gonna do less than 20
points you could do less or if Laura
Croft or whatever is going to have uh
30 points you could say more than 25 so
it's just you could pick on all the
different players Cino Moy freaking uh
Brock Les uh not Brock Lesnar who else
BR uh Bryce HT no they have I don't know
uh oh Joe flacko Bro now what dude smoke
a gram for your homies BR Joe
Flo oh more than two touchdowns bro um
so there's just a lot of options but if
you are smart with sports and you know
what players are going to perform on
what night prize picks is the best app
for you download the app and use code
Theo prize picks will match your deposit
up to
$100 there's a lot of great Duos out
there in the world starzy and
Hutch um Kane and Abel who else Key and
Peele a lot of different folks that when
they combine they do it perfectly so
what's the perfect Duo when it comes to
Growing your business that's you and
Shopify Shopify is the global Commerce
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your business from the launch
your online shop stage to the first real
life store stage all the way to the did
we just hit a million orders stage
Shopify to help you grow Shopify turns
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms what I love about uh
Shopify is that no matter how big you
want to grow they can help you scale all
along the way you know and I say scale
like I know everything what I'm talking
about I don't I read it on this ad sign
up for a $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com thee all lowercase go to s h
oy.com
EO now to grow your business no matter
what stage you're in shopify.com
[Music]
Theo my mom yeah after my dad I she she
dated a couple guys but not did she
Remar yeah she ended up she's doing good
then she's doing good yeah she's doing
good she lives out in Arizona she's my
mom's cool lady you call the stepdad uh
he passed away he was in the war or
whatever and then he passed away [__]
War
yeah he was uh but what war I'm not sure
but he wore like a lot of gloves at the
end of his life and he liked having
gloves on I remember the war bro you're
40 years old dude you got like I don't
think Vietnam happened what we talking
about dude the war he was in the Great
War
and the second war 1942 1912 yeah pull
up a war Nick he was in the war Desert
Storm bro like what's war no he wasn't
in desert stor dude no he was in like
the War I don't know maybe the war on
drugs or something the war pull up uh
recent Wars or whatever the War on Drugs
that was the that was Bush's wife right
the
war yeah what war we talking about here
dude dude you needed pick pick a war
Persian golf probably that K du baby
Korean War maybe okay what
1950 maybe I don't know he would
definitely I know if we you know what I
know he would uh he would take my mom to
this what I'm talking about it guys he
would take my own Chinese food but when
the waiter walked off he would [__]
say some [__] but I'm talking about with
the bro I don't guys I don't [__]
know if he's a genius or [__] he just
goes either way dude how about this
there's way many options in between BR
you just said your you just said your
dad number two was in the [__] War
yeah he was dude he had a sword at the
[__] house dude he left it to my
mother he left a autographed sword or
whatever or what I don't know what that
who the [__] autographed the chy man he
killed dude pull up something Nick Jesus
Christ look at us we don't know what the
[__] we're talking hey give this guy
give this guy a bone dude when I did the
Rogan podcast what what's Rogan's Guy
what's Rogan's like a Jamie Jamie dude I
was thrown off by Jamie yeah oh man I
think I think ran I think ran abuses him
dude really I think I think he confuses
him like what he like I don't know D I
think stay up late or something like I
think I was picturing like a like a like
a like a like a younger white nerdy kid
you know no he's angry he's an angry man
Jamie he's [__] angry bro who Jamie
Jamie's angry is he I don't know he just
seems like dialed in he's like a he's
like a marksman for information but I
think I think I think Rogan disciplines
him oh you think yeah cuz you'll see it
dude every now and then Rogan will let
that [__] slip there he is right there
look how jacked he's getting too yeah
dude is that that's not Jamie is it
that's that's that's Jamie on the left
can you zoom in on him oh man
dude oh yeah yeah but like every now and
then you'll see like you'll see Rogan
discipline him like he'll speak out of
turn
and you'll see it on like you you I mean
your guys have seen that and he'll like
but he'll just like discipline like no
no Jamie not that the other one oh yeah
like he like you could tell it's like
that abusive father that like you know
is that the soccer game that like like
slips a little bit like sh pass that
[__] yeah and you're like oh [__] I
wonder what it's like when the when the
when you're at home by himself yeah so I
think Jamie I think Jamie gets [__] up
a little bit I wonder if he does some
things or anything like that to him what
if he has a little thing under the thing
where he presses and it no he what's the
thing the the four fingers dude yo Jamie
let us know dude let us know if you're
in danger but yeah I think I think he
gets disciplines but you can tell like
Theo don't discipline his guys they look
happy uh I don't know about that we get
into some [__] sometimes I mean but
sometimes it's tough because you are
you're thinking and they're thinking and
you're not the same brain and so you're
both trying to figure out like I mean
they're thinking bro we don't know about
you we haven't decided yet the war yet
we haven't [__] decided yet dude this
guy's taking more this guy has [__]
well
we this guy has three letters in his
alphabet dude and two of them are CT and
I'm the [__] deranged guy dude you
just attacked a guy in a [__] movie
theater last night and I'm the [__]
crazy guy bro well hey here's the thing
man when the time comes to it I if the
time comes to it where I need to a man I
hope that I [__] man up and do it how
would you do
it well it depends how bad I wanted yeah
I mean like but what would you do man is
is it going to be a beating is it going
to be a choking is it just going to be
sheer pressure you know it is man from
like a psychological perspective I think
it's like uh what do they say I have
like antisocial personality disorder
yeah you know what that is really I
don't know if I see that though you seem
pretty social like you seem I didn't
know I learned it I saw when I remember
seeing you at slap fights I remember
thinking you know there's something
extremely Charming about Shawn there's
something that is very um extreme high
functioning sociopath I wouldn't say
high functioning high functioning okay
no offense dude call down this guy has
an autograph [__] War memorabilia
dude bro I'm [__] trying to help you
get a free sword when my mother passes
away you're not even [__] being cool
about it dude but I don't want I don't
want it from the dead China man bro but
no he they would go to the Chinese
buffet and [__] they loved it and it
was like pretty cheap and so but as soon
as the waiter walked off my [__]
stepdad would say a bunch of [__] about
him hey you know you know it's funny to
me the
chinan so I hit a China man once like
driving you hit one yeah like he was SL
my fault oh well it's all but yeah but
they have done it so much I remember
dude like yeah what I thought they
started it for sure but I remember the
moment like cuz I got out to go check on
the guy I put him into a [__] wall
dude airbag airbags deployed airbags
[__] deployed
right yeah so I go and I remember like
have to go check on him well dude I mean
a like d literally [__] 50 mes 60 M
hour [__] wall like the guy was
probably [__] up a little bit yeah
yeah so
anyways I go and the first I think like
oh my God I hit a nation oh yeah yeah
yeah but then a part of me was like man
it's almost probably Bad Karma yeah oh
you think well I don't know if I hit oh
I'll tell you this I I remember this
Chinese guy he could have been also
maybe Korean but he hit me one time oh
dude I I love that skit you did with the
the little Asian guy the short dude
[__] he's your he's your friend
Riley M the China man dude the China man
dude well he's he's Polynesian I think
he definitely got a famous sauce out of
oh yeah I fought I fought a China man in
the Philippines dude look at you
Japanese guys nice guy dud nice guy be
his ass for five rounds dude sometimes
bro real talk real honestly dude a plane
crashes right you got to eat an
ethnicity out of the gate Asian soft
tender my man dude I've been saying that
yeah and people are like disagree with
me in the street I think black I think
dark Meek would be tough like mascular
vascular you know black people are in
this den and now if you're having a big
dinner if you're having a Thanksgiving
or something and you're still out there
with but how come you haven't got that
man like I don't I don't pay for sex D
but like does he just not want to [__]
what's the deal he has some type of um
STD no as so why you can't [__] bro we
used to have I used to have a couple of
mentally unwell buddies and we would go
to the Rada dude and steal all the
[__] plants out of the lobby and
stuff while the guy was out there
smoking and uh you the Buddy
no you were the men you guys were
awesome bro oh this is a true story so I
went into did the Rogan podcast right
and dude and Rogan put me up in a nice
little spot oh you have four seasons it
was a [__] convention bro I [__] you
not I'm not even [__] joking till one
day convention and so literally dude it
was just like I feel like it was like a
a a tender bro like all these are just
going there shacking up and [__] each
other really and I don't hate on it bro
I mean I don't [__] hate on it but
I'll never forget
I'll never forget dude mean angry little
angry little [__] little person Yeah
Yeah well yeah some people say a little
person some people don't care some of
them care some of them don't I know I
have a friend some of my friends they
say little people I don't know enough I
don't have a consensus to know what's
the best thing to say there was like a
little angry looking little dude you
know every now they got some good look
oh yeah my buddies uh my mom's H
ex-husband same guy that died the war
guy uh and he um his best friend married
a uh little person oh no [__] and they
had a child that was a little person I
remember that's so [__] up dude and he
no it is it was a good little kid I'd be
so pissed off dude look at that man you
telling me that boy I'd be pissed on
shorty looking nice boy imagine that
dude imagine you tell your girl it's
time to go and she's like pick her up
walk
away that's a [__] move bro this dude
is a world that dude is a king bro no
yeah he's a king of little people but
that's Tyran what's his name
tyrannis Joffrey Tyran so anyway let me
finish my [__] story dude so this
[__] this little [__] backs his
ass up in the elevator right and there's
a little by the number pad and she goes
oh what number do you need I was oh you
know number like e or some [__] you know
you know Rogan put me the very bottom
floor I was in no pen house but it was
nice so you know it was nice IID expect
a I mean how much is Rogan how much your
net worth bro come on you can't you
can't give me a sweet you can't give me
a bode or some [__] dud what the [__]
Rogan I mean what the [__] bro you know
what I'm saying you can't buy me a
dinner dude you just [__] you put me
in you with the m anyways you in there
yeah I think he might did to [__] with
me too because you know Rogan would do
that like hey let's find this a hotel
there's a little person convention so
anyways I tell been there did you tell
them they were there when you went no
man you know me and Rogan dude you know
it's like we're like friend of M so
anyways like so I I tell the little the
little person like you know number seven
and she looks at me she was like I
wasn't talking to you I was talking to
him and I was like [__] like you're an
angry little person but did you say like
hey number seven bu no I'm I'm polite
I'm a polite man dude anyways but yeah
so what I'm thinking dude the little
people are mean yeah they're not like
the hobbits bro they're like the other
people uh I'm trying to think it was
there was there some little people that
were famous for being mean I'm trying to
think dude my favorite my favorite show
Growing Up was that show you
[__] God man uh I don't know dude
that the second I've tried to have any
decent thoughts here everything said
Sean is taking me completely into the 11
Trying by the way you guys if somebody
would ask me right now hey Sean would
you [__] I wouldn't be like I want I
don't know like no I'm good man it's not
really my type this man if someone put a
gun in my head right now and they said
Sean do you think Theo Von is ever
[__] I don't know what I would say I
think I would I would really and I'm
dude I'm impressed I'm impressed dude
like here's the thing I have this buddy
I'm not going to name the guy but like
you could say if he's a black guy or not
though oh he's definitely black for sure
where this where this is going like I I
admire I admire you as a Man He's a
brave guy for putting your dick in that
yeah we're talking about me that next
dude oh really oh yeah he's good looking
dude get a lot of [__] goodl looking
dude I would get so scared I think if
somebody was like really you mean like
the escorts you called yeah I would just
oh there were some women that I would
just be like this is just I don't need
to be doing this they don't need to be
doing this you know it was not the best
yeah meeting yeah no I bet you've done
some dirty [__] dude you just seem like
that you got a mullet bro I bet I bet
you got some stores dude dude it's cuz I
look like [__] doesn't mean I'm a bad
guy or you're a bad why are you a bad
guy for [__] horse that doesn't make
you a bad guy yeah that's true might
makes you a scumbag but not a bad guy
yeah but also here's the thing they are
a lot of women are looking for sex well
a lot of women are having a sell sex
these days which is crazy anyway that's
one thing that's a little bit I'll say
one thing about women dude and this is
something needs to be said
yeah no no no I'm curious as to what it
is think about like every mass shooting
ever happen Okay
like every match should ever happened at
one point that man went to go get some
[__] yeah he went to go get some [__]
he had some woman say like nah [__] I
ain't I ain't gonna suck your dick I
ain't gonna suck your dick and what I'm
saying you is women need to put out more
because no man has ever walked into a
mall or a school and say know I got so
much [__] [__] I got so much [__]
[__] guys I just couldn't [__] take
it I couldn't [__] take it so yeah
you don't see Ric
Flair you know yeah oh my God there's so
much [__] I'm gonna lose my [__] so
it's like you don't see them see him
shooting up a uh a Chili's like bar in
the so what I'm saying is like at what
point don't women take responsibility
for not putting out putting out but do
you think men are appropriate do they
men behave appropriately enough and
operate appropriately enough to deserve
like that's another thing here thing a
lot of dudes show up pretty much like
you know dudes will drive by it's
yelling [__] from me and [__] like that
it's like that's not even taking a woman
out you know for every for every really
hot woman you guys meet that won't [__]
you guess what she's [__] somebody
else like what I'm saying mean about
that so
like say you go meet a princess right
you meet this chick that she you [__]
love this chick [__] love this chick
she's world you want to marry her oh
yeah and say she's not putting out well
I guarantee dude she's not putting out
for you but she's putting out for
somebody else a so what I'm saying dude
women man rud of all problem rud of all
we shouldn't have them [__] vote dude
you think oh [__] yeah dude women suck
dude women men vote for all kind of
shitty things look at that [__] why
the why the women vote for that because
the things getting [__] for every
liberal for every liberal man he's doing
it because there's some dirty liberal
feminist woman he's trying to
[__] oh that could be true that's weird
that now that's a pretty crazy anytime
no this is facts this is [__] facts I
don't know if it is what is it every
time no it's facts bro it's facts every
time a man is with a liberal woman dude
you just see the [__] soul just being
sucked out of his body liberal women bro
[__] ay got to put him back in the
[__] kitchen dude well I think if you
want to think about God there's so many
things going on here um I don't know how
you survive Sean you're wild dude it's
true though dude it's true though what
what is one well let's talk about one
thing at a time okay what's one what's
one good thing a woman ever added to
society well you could start off with a
milair heart [__] got lost okay look we
prefer the term Mia yeah there we go
okay but uh yeah she's still missing um
I will say that right yeah but that I
mean look at this picture dude of her
getting in this plane you're like where
if this lady isn't going just to the
mall we're [__] you know like what I'm
saying D let's look at let's look at
America let's this this is 19 win was it
Nick but we gave women too much power
look at cam Harrison bro we gave these
[__] too much power oh dude we did it
for [__] dude and this is what I try to
tell you guys okay this is what I this
is the part I we do it for [__] [__]
you think guys are saying hey I want to
make love to this lady so I'm going
to give them the right to vote or the
right to that
like I guess right BR when you're a kid
when you're a kid like you know you
compromise yourself to get laid we all
yeah no but I'm saying dude and this is
what I'm trying to tell you guys yeah
what is it like there used to be again
I'm not a [__] I'm not a Muslim I
don't believe in that [__] you know I
believe like take off the [__] burka
Slims we call them yeah Slims bro take
off the burka put on a bikini you know
what's that what's that little porn star
Nam katif oh uh the the Willie Katana
huh I don't [__] know her dude I I
don't know I don't watch it dude I have
a feeling now though you know Zuck I bet
Zuck isn't some weird [__] dude Mark
Zuckerberg but that's because of money
he's not my Instagram dude no but is he
but rich people get into weird stuff
because they run out of um cuz just
[__] becomes something poor people do
D but we got off subject we're talking
about men and we got off every we
haven't been on a subject we're talking
about men and women here dude we is that
we're talking about men and women so
like what I'm saying dude men used to be
men like there used to be a time and a
place D where like go [__] chop down
trees and you know go [__] conquer
Nations go fight the Indians and then
all of a sudden bro we just let these
[__] women but I don't think it's cuz
of women let me think uh well here's
here's right here 10 incredible
inventions by women that change the
world let's look at some of them the
circular
saw yeah I don't know about that [__]
dude okay the dishwasher bro the life
WTH the life raft all this [__] like
yeah we hey the life hold on we didn't
need a dishwasher bro why you think
about women well look of course they're
going to invent the dishwasher that's
kind of a no-brainer right give you that
one they trying to make their life a
little bit easier listen God made you
guys with hands for a reason dude one of
my first jokes was go if God didn't want
you in the kitchen oh if God didn't want
you to cook why did he put milk and eggs
in your body oh well there we go it's
facts but what I'm saying you guys
that's facts bro that's facts what I'm
saying some white guys saying that in
the back of the Durango Casino out here
in Las Vegas Nevada Off the Strip but
beautiful and safe yeah we're in a nice
we're in a nice place dude there's a lot
of [__] you guys like this [__] you
come swing by yeah that's another way to
advertise it though I think we covered
both but dude that's like here's the
thing like I can see you being a car
salesman dude get on over here to Sean's
cars huh and you just beat it beat
somebody into the car like get in the
[__] car you yeah don't be a [__]
[__] dude your wife's going go [__] the
neighbor if you don't buy this car your
neighbor has this [__] car you want
to start [__] the neighbor no but
like dude I love like I'm such an
advocate for women but like they've lost
their place well it became Financial
dude that's what happened women women
were tired of like oh men have the money
so that they can cuz men started being
abusive to women it wasn't like men were
being cool to women if men were being
cool to women they'd been like yeah I I
can just be a mom and take care of the
home no no dude what what happened I'll
tell you guys what happened it's gonna
be a little rant you're gonna bear with
me yeah I've been bearing with all of
this yeah so I'll tell you what happened
look I don't know what happened
corporations are the [__] devil oh
yeah they are the [__] devil bro they
are they are the enemy of the Free
People this is God I [__] hate them
yeah I meanless they get us money
[__] a you know [__] pull out your
latte yeah I'll take a little money from
him but after that [__] you again F so
and who are you talking about McDonald
who are you talking about say it xon no
I mean all of them all of them dude and
it's getting worse so this is where like
I'm such a big advocate for men and I'm
i i i i people take me as I hate on wom
but I don't I just look at history for
what happened during World War II yeah
whenever there was a shortage of you
know men making bombs and [__] we had to
pull the women out of the kitchen worse
thing we've ever [__] did dude [__]
you Hitler worst thing we ever [__]
did so because we took women out of
being moms right no so what we did is
and they had to become so afterward I
afterward I we're in the situation now
where we have you know more we have
Labor that's like Rosie the Riveter
right like whenever they had the yeah
[__] that dude [__]
that you ruined [__] America Rosie
get your ass back in the kitchen but she
I don't know and this woman I think also
was in the women too if you zoom in on
her oh yeah no I'm I'm not
asham that's the only thing I'd like to
watch you do anyways so what happened
dude is you you have
[Music]
like the corporations are in line with
the government to make people [__]
slaves they make people slaves for our
cell phones and make people slaves so
what what you have happening is they
realize that when you get more people
working more people
consume so we've artificially lowered
pay we've increased spending we've we've
done inflation like it is all a scam
from corporations that own our
government to make men make less to make
men do work do more to make the value of
man go down this is why they're trying
to like blur the gender lines there was
a point in in American history when you
got [__] for instance we want to talk
about government
yeah we've spent more on
Ukraine infrastructure or whatever the
[__] it is than we've spent in the year
in building roads oh I think it's
unbelievable we've we've we've could
have financed cancer treatments for all
Americans for you know what a [__]
five years I mean the numbers are there
oh we could have solved crimes we could
have done what else could we have done
so what I'm saying there was a point in
American history I'm I'm I'm January 6
supporter half you can't tell yeah it's
going to demonetize now but there was a
point in American history say January
7th then January 7th January 7th but
there was a point in American history
where like you would tell a man that hey
we're going to take 33% of your paycheck
out of your check and we're going to go
give it to [__] Ukraine we're going
to go give it to [__] Israel we're
going to go give it to where everybody
else that's not [__] you right the
only people who haven't been affected by
inflation politicians you think these
[__] paying K pay cuts you
think they're getting you think whenever
it comes time backs yeah you think when
it comes time that but this is what
we've done by letting women infect us
this is what we've done we've blurred
the lines and look now they're trying to
take away now they're trying to just
completely that's why I make the
connection a little bit because I'm with
you whenever you get like yes they're
trying to make men weak they're trying
to make the Lines Blurred that's why
even when I said when I was thinking
about China when you're there you don't
everything just seems like a group of
people that follow whatever the next
notification on their phone is that go
to work that have no feelings left a lot
of times and I'm not judging all Chinese
people just saying a general feeling you
get it's not women it's not women it's
it's people understanding that like you
don't want two Sexes you want a blurred
line of [__] working robots and and
but they've slowly they like like look
at look at you know income tax that
wasn't a [__] thing until like what
19 when when did income tax become a
thing
1912 I mean I don't [__] when did
they do it huh pull up [__] see
I tried that all
right there was a there was one in a
1861 no that was a short period tax for
a war effort okay but they made it a
federal law when did federal income tax
start fulltime yeah fulltime say what
1814 1914 this man [__] knows this
man [__]
knows
1914 but what you need to understand
dude there is a point in in human
history and being a man I mean we fought
a [__] War yeah I remember my [__]
stepdad was in it he was [__] in it
he got a sword from the [__] English
he fought the red coat dude [__] this
man told you man's a lineage of
Heroes but there was a point where they
would say Hey you would come take 30 33%
of my pay I'm going to kill you you
can't [__] do that and now you don't
have a choice anymore and now you're
going to go and you're going to give it
to Ukraine you're going to give to all
these other [__] countries I agree I
say [__] those other places that we
should and and we don't have even have a
choice anymore it's like no matter who
you vote for because they took the nuts
because they took the nuts away from men
but I feel like they did in this
backhanded way where they just slowly
slowly right oh so slowly I mean they
took a little bit of nut at a time you
didn't even notice it was missing and
then suddenly and next you know you got
no nuts dude now it's like women got nut
now now women have more nuts than we
women have the nuts dude dude oh dude
it's crazy now if you want to [__]
jerk off you got to ask your wife for
your dick half the time ask [__] Gary
you hear about that who did I and Gary
bro uhuh what happened to him no [__]
dud his wife's wag bro really yeah wag
but we ignore that we're talking about
we
we're we're talking about America dude
oh she's all right no she's all right
dude I mean she's not all right I mean
she is fine though she's fine for old
lady she is I'll give you a gist of it
okay Ian Gary Ian Gary I know who he is
young stud bro young he just got he just
got [__] pneumonia and [__] he had to
pull off his fire pneumonia right I
guess I guess that's pneumonia is the
words for fear anyways his wife wrote a
book on how to be a wag and a wag is
pretty much what is it whites against
what there we go got up I mean she's f
bro she's fine am I missing
it pretty much she wrote a book on how
our wrot a book on how to yeah when but
that was and dude we didn't have any
Mexicans we had one kid that was like
pseudo Chinese Riverside it was usually
Whit and Mexicans were against blacks oh
really yeah Riverside dude you know
blacks and Aliens don't get along dude
yeah that's facts dude that's a [__]
that I've been hearing dude and you know
who told me that blacks [__] I think
you say blacks bro it's African-American
sorry
African-American blacks yeah it's all
right you're pretty much black bro I
wouldn't say that no you're black dude
I'm not you get a pass I'm not trying to
get one you don't know what I'm saying
dude look I'm not breaking out my pth in
front of people and be like hey this
[__] wig bro I just hope dude I just
hope no one ever plays racist chicken
with me like if somebody ever plays
racist I'm gonna lose guys and you're
gonna have to give me some credit cuz
I'm gonna [__] lose I'm going to no
racist chicken me I'm going to lose I'm
gonna [__] lose well I think there
should be I think if you do well enough
in a
year you should I'm not saying you
should be able to say whatever you want
but I think this should give you a half
hour what it's a song what if it's a
good song like this this is the n word
oh that is okay I think if you paid to
if you paid whatever the fee is on Apple
Tunes or whatever yeah you should say it
I think you should time you know I don't
think but maybe you pay every time you
use we got two [__] this man's this
man's brain is fried from drugs mine
brain is fried from brain damage so
we're just kind of [__] all over the
place here I can't help it sorry guys I
think we're doing fine yeah but what I'm
saying is this buddy is that if you what
were you saying yeah [__] blue chew
baby time to chew your way into just
weener Wonderland that's what it is baby
Chomp on that little chewy Bell and next
thing you know baby you got that dang
flag post Bubba you'll have a neighbor
come down hang a uh hang an Easter flag
off your off your rod y fil blue chew
that's what they do it's a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Calis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost the best part is
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blueo free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
$5 shipping that's B
cw.com promo code t h EO to receive your
first month free visit blue.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank blue for sponsoring the
podcast this episode is brought to you
by better help you know around New Years
we often get obsessed with how to change
ourselves and how to adjust ourselves or
do something different you know maybe
get a new B you know get a new back
brace or join a
gym um but better help is also an option
if you're struggling with how you think
or feel if your life maybe doesn't fit
like it used to or you just want to
maybe have some help adjusting your
perspective um some of those things
could just be normal life but if it gets
to be too much you may need help and
better help offers that if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time I've tried better
help so I'll let you know that it works
and you can visit betterhelp.com
tho today to get 10% off your first
month that's better
hp.com Theo if you're wondering about
hair loss I'm trying to keep mine I got
to hell I got this hat on it right now
it can't go anywhere if it's really if
it's in the Hat that's how I feel but if
you want to keep yours and you're you
don't want to have not have any hair one
day like one of them hairless cats then
keeps can help you keeps can help you
get expert care for hair loss from the
comfort of your home without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
treatment is delivered right to your
door on your schedule you can opt for
shipments every 3 6 or 12 months
whatever works best for you keeps offers
both of the FDA approved hair loss
treatment options as well as a twoin one
gel that combines both treatments hair
loss stops with keeps for a special
offer to get started go to
keeps.com Theo or click the link in the
description that's ke ps.com
[Music]
EO thank you guys for supporting the
podcast what I'm saying is this buddy is
that if you what were you saying yeah
[__] we're talking about wag so Gary
bro he's like this young St 26 his
wife's like [__] 40 something right I
mean she's a good-looking woman they're
both very handsome I mean I about thate
kind looks like Gary's a handsome look
at his child mean his beautiful kid bro
I know that it looks all
dark what I mean if you look at the skin
tone looks a little dark we also I have
no clue what the tones on this monitor
are set at but that mean tell me that
kid does not look a little dark go back
zoom in on the child the child looks
very
[Music]
happy I don't know man that kid looks
happy but yeah what does the kid look
like though look like he and Gary little
twin little it's weird because you're
supposed to look like your dad when
you're born too he's tall he's Irish as
well isn't he he's got to be the tallest
Irishman huh he's very tall is he so
anyways moving on dude moving on moving
on dude moving on so the wife went
through like she got [__] ran through
on the soccer scene so she wrote a book
on how to be a wag on how to be a famous
woman with an athlete or how to be a
woman with an athlete yeah [__] wrote a
book about this like eight years I don't
know eight years ago okay so she go
there's a book how to be whack and dude
she's fine bro she's fine for an old
lady she's fine yeah she looks pretty to
me yeah I know I'm like five years like
in 10 years she's gonna hit that Gil
status you know
but you're gonna get me beat up by yary
dude [__] inary bro so yeah you can
say that dude I have to just be some guy
wandering ing around backstage at a UFC
event looking for a water fountain or
something and Ian Gary comes down the
hall dude he going to do [__] bro you're
going to do his wife's a wag so anyways
yeah but that's anyways when I have to
say hello so this young man who probably
didn't got all the [__] he goes and
falls into this black hole right and
then the sucky [__] is why I like to
call her he's a victim but what why do
you have it out for this guy I don't
have it out for this guy it's just like
it's insane to me that
like this woman wrote a book on how to
[__] date famous next thing you know
she's with you she's like what 15 how
much older is is she than him 15 15
years she's 15 years older she's 40 30
years older 13 years 13 years older bro
like it's not that much older is it it's
not but like you're a young [__] stud
dude and you're with like this older
okay
furthermore he uh further more I like
that yeah no we we'll continue this no
no I don't yeah I just so he changed his
last name
to Ian Gary Machado I remember that to
match the ex-husband's last name her
ex-husband yes bro no
way I mean what do we say to that dude
the [__] do we say to that Ian Gary
Machado Ian Gary Machado imado Gary what
is it Nick what middle name last name it
don't [__] hypen name it don't
[__] matter but what is your issue
here I don't understand what that's not
an issue bro it's just [__] up it's
like you just like it just [__] up
dude she's a succubus okay and you
should like no like why did no why did
this man not have a I mean he got kicked
out of the gym because her
so is actually her M name that's been
often said that it was her ex-husband's
name that G but it's it was her original
M name okay so I'm I I'm I I'm saying
I'm getting fact checked yeah there's a
little Twitter box fact check yeah yeah
um yeah so that's not it so wait wait
how come either way either way dude I
mean or do you have to fight him or not
no I mean I'll don't give I'll [__]
startch that that man I'll kill that man
anyways Dam bro you can bro you have
killed I don't know if we're going to
get in trouble because you've killed two
people during this thing no I've not
kill I'm just saying like you know push
comes to shove you know [__] push
always comes to shove with you it seems
like because um yeah you just push that
guy what I'm saying what I'm saying is I
would never want to make fun of his and
I I I hope and G I hope you and your
family I hope you guys have a long life
and you good thing that they don't make
Viagra for women because you know oh man
you F I mean how does that work how does
that work when you hit like d you love
this [__] dude do you like talking [__]
more since you've had more success
recently or did you think about talking
[__] as much back I mean am I talking I
mean oh God damn D they probably got
that from the
ex-husband well herpes oh D dude little
herpes that was a black rapper name you
don't hear much huh herpes is more of a
white thing huh I mean I don't [__]
know got herpes you don't hear a lot of
black guys like yeah got ever if you
ever went to [__] chick who's told
you she's had
herpes I'm not that good at sex man so I
don't wait you've never been like you've
never had a girl back and like they I've
never had a stalker you've they've never
thrown I've never had a girl like passed
back you never you never they've never
thrown out a disclaimer like hey I've
had I've had hepatitis A once no I think
a is a curable one right yeah B for bad
yeah but you never you never had a girl
you never had a girl like come throw out
a disclaimer like hey I'm on the on The
Vow tracks so no actually you know what
I did date a girl one time and I don't
remember what her name was it could have
been Susan but I don't think it was
Susan but um she said that she
had
um herpes simplex or something so we
couldn't have sex but we didn't date
that long we only went on about three
dates I don't think she liked me that
much you couldn't have sex or she or she
oh I I didn't want to have sex with her
it made me nervous right yeah so I
already get nervous if I have to use
like conom just the whole it all makes
me nervous dude you use condoms it all
makes me nervous I would say
[Music]
that you know but I'm just saying
like someone's be coming up hey
someone's GNA come up with this man D go
have this man's baby he's just BL he's
just blowing loads all over the place
dud you're a [__] weirdo dude I'm got
to tell you that yeah yeah you're
telling me that you tell me that you
[__] dated chick the herpes you want
to [__] her cuz she didn't you didn't
use condoms dude you came on here you
freaking bashed my stepdad who died okay
who had Alzheimer's Dementia or whatever
and he wore those nice gloves how the
[__] are you supposed to believe he was
a warv I know I'm not saying he was a
perfect guy but I will say this he owned
a car wash and he was pretty decent he
used to take us to Holiday in to have
breakfast do you give your sister money
at all yeah I do give her some money
what she do for work she is a waitress I
mean you got to be balling bro we're in
the Durango we're in the back room we're
in the Velvet Room you got to be balling
bro yeah I didn't rent this they [__]
some this manager let us in he's out of
his mind yeah I know but you're like a
famous guy now dude you're like you
Tucker Dana White Tucker Carlson bro
you're the [__] man bro these are not
it's not like it's not like you get
Trump yet Trump interview yet no I think
he would maybe come on though bro you
gotta get Trump on here dude you gonna
fall on his dick like Colby no dude
you're not gonna fall on his dick I will
say this man what did you think about
I'm not gonna say anything what did you
think about that kby thing Co the kobby
thing first of all it was one of those
fights where like the guys just I don't
know I think I got kicked the [__] out
oh yeah that's right huh yeah to [__]
leave your own job you piece of [__] you
can't even [__] clock in and finish
your shift that's fair I've never had a
job I know no dude but uh bro have you
ever seen why they take why didn't they
take dupus out I [__] I don't he was the
one that called me out he want to try to
fight me he did it and because here's
what's funny is I'm I'm leaving after
the show last night and uh and he's in
the back right I start talking I didn't
know that that that that that that that
was him right I I I remember that there
was a South African guy yeah he dude I
think his coach might [__] him actually
P hey pulled up show show show the
man what's the coach's name Ron yeah
just type in coach kissing drus or
grabbing his dick I mean it should be
one of the first things that comes up
but now some of this is a cultural thing
buddy I don't know dude you get your
dick grabbed a law in South
Africa that could be made up
huh could be made up what about what
about do the wow he's strong huh yeah
he's in there dude he's in there Fu I I
you know I wouldn't kiss him but I would
[__] i' I get close goodbye we grab
we give a little little nut grab no I'm
not touching somebody's [__] nuts
that's insane whoa whoa that's not this
okay that's crazy dude I that's an
Embrace though bro this he seems like a
very nice guy I um but I didn't know
that was I didn't I don't think that
that's him yeah hey were you were you
sitting by Trump last night I was
sitting down from him did you go and
shake his hand and get a picture oh I
went and shook his hand I said hey when
he walk in did you didn't get a picture
I didn't get a picture yeah oh what the
[__] dude I've gotten a picture with him
before is it cool uh yeah a lot of likes
uh I didn't put it up oh that's that's
what's up dude yeah I just don't know
how I mean like I I like Trump I like
but I don't know I I think I don't know
I wish I knew him better as a person did
you vote for you didn't vote you know it
seem like you vote oh I have voted I
voted two times yeah oh [__] who' you
vote for I voted for Obama and Trump but
every every white man had to votee for
Obama that was like I'm not a racist
vote for Obama no look I wish they get a
real dark brother I wish they get damn
Trick Daddy in that [__] cuz Denzel
Washington you know huh like a Denzel
Washington no I like dark zel Washington
I want to go real [__] out there yeah
I want to get like man uh who's that
damn that's him huh bro have you ever
seen Trump wave we got to fix his wave
dude he walked by he walked by like the
the crowd and he has like this little
gay like limp wristed wave like he does
super gay bro super gay I don't know why
his handle is going to fix that [__]
he's also getting older he's up late
yeah you still don't have to wave like a
like a fairy yeah when do you remember
the first time that you went um we got
to change the conversation because we've
never we Haven even started the
interview um I gotta I got I'm like
looking for a cup to piss in yeah take a
p take a break real quick no it's okay
we continue I mean I'm holding I'm G get
my got my if you have to Peter in a
fight what do you guys do does the pee
go away after a while you ever I think
you're trying to kill a man dude yeah
look at the wave D the wave's [__]
that's a better wave yeah like The
Little Wave like somebody sees out of
wave it's good um I did think it was a
little like at the end that when Kobe
was still talking about like he's like
the War of 1812 or whatever that he was
like yelling about the dec whatever he
was yell at the end it was just like
yeah no Kobe's you would let Colby
really he's a weak man like what do you
mean by it so like Colby was very boring
at one point in his career and it got to
a point where were like they pretty much
said like HBY like you got to you got to
be more exciting and then he created
like the Covington you know he created
this [__] guy and you know I mean
[__] it worked out well for him but
he's just like fraudulent like even when
it came to uh George nasal like okay for
instance oh yeah him and massol fought
each other yeah so I mean this guy like
threatened his kids and [__] he said
some [__] about his kids you don't quote
me I I know we got the [__] fact
Checkers back here dude I mean he was
like he insulted his kids you know
massal being is he Mexican what mall
Cuban Mexican huh Cuban he's something
foreign you know he's something foreign
and scary he's like a kind of guy that
like if you were at an ATM machine and
he walked up behind you look but maybe
but once he smiled though George has the
best smile no you would know he's there
for if that man's behind you at an at
machine that little [__] mirror that
looks you might not even looking it you
would feel alarmed I think at first if
you just saw him walk up with his hands
behind his back kind of oh yeah no that
man's definitely going to [__] rob
look this guy
yeah this guy wow so anyways and then
Colby he's just a c dude he's just a
[__] you ever Su you ever Su a man I
never have sued a man I don't think I'd
probably have sued somebody oh he's been
sued somebody U-turn into me while I was
doing some cocaine on the side of the
road I'd parked and uh a couple of girls
u-turned and T-Bone me right there so
you sued them yeah well how old wait
wait how but you're you're a wealthy man
prob six years ago well you were not
wealthy yet when did your wealth come I
started making a little him on the last
year oh so now you're recently wealthy
yeah cuz I remember you dude you were
like you were like a Joe Rogan's like
I'm not going to say lacky but like you
know he' get you on there you get some
hype I like going on there but dude now
got to talk now you're like a Rogan bro
like I would don't say there is like the
Theo of Honor you're an equal now bro
you no that's insane yes you are dude
maybe no that's insane I even thought
about that two times just now it's a
really bad that's a no you're like an
equal now I like equals dude maybe to
you have I me it's very it's nice you to
say I like dude I like Rogan's podcast
and it was funan is so smart he's so
smart and he's so curious got g a
[__] he get your microphone off the
dick bro get your get your mouth off the
dick bro BR I don't need I don't uh I
don't feel like I R I like I I respect
who he is I've thought a lot about this
people say that a lot yeah you're going
deep on that well he's a I think he's a
rare individual I think he's extremely
rare I think you guys are rare I think
there's a lot of I mean at this point
you're talking about Rarity you're
talking about very rare people I'm just
[__] I'm just me yeah but you're
really athletic at it yeah which is
weird right I'm saying dude you know how
many and I'm not gonna Jud I don't [__]
with the chaperon you guys shout out to
all the [__] our boys where I'm from
but you know how many mentally people
have no shot at the level at what you're
doing yeah Fu well fighting bro it's
easy at the end of the day all you all
you gotta do is hit a [__] all
you gotta do is just hit a guy but you
know when you jump back so after the D
when the dupes thing what's going on
your head you're like that you think
about the stuff he said yesterday you're
like I'm going to go say something well
no it was just more that he said let's
fight like right now wait he said it
from right then yeah so you heard him
say let's fight and then I you know you
know Gilbert Burns he has a lovely
family bro nobody's more fun to watch
watch watch the fights than watching
Gilbert's family it is the most should
be a live stream just on them watching
the fight [__] the UFC [__] the UFC they
know that I'm stable they know that I
like every time the UFC asked me to go
to an event I'm like you guys you know
what like they'll ask me to go like look
at his family though like they asked me
to go hang out with kid rocket some [__]
that's not going to end well yeah and
I'm like yeah know it's just better it's
just better if I don't leave my house
like it's not like you're putting me in
a bad situation yeah so they knew that
they knew what they were [__] doing
they put me in a bad situation do you
think they did it on purpose though I
don't I think they did it because they
wanted a shot but I didn't think think
they I don't know if they thought it
would go that far right CU Dana said
that it was his fault but what they did
though they put kids behind me so
they're smart like know what we're going
to do we're going to put some we're
gonna put some [__] little little
little we Lads behind Shawn and the and
the coach [__] right but but here's
the crazy part though look at you here
you go Sean right
there now was this stage did you guys
act this out backstage or anything no no
it's all real and then he just sits
there run his [__] mouth dude he just
run his [__] mouth is he saying stuff
to you yeah he's like he's like saying
look at me like [__] you and then you
know I just kindly asked the
wife did you feel like you got any good
licks on him or not oh I land some good
12 to six elbows he seemed totally fine
when I saw him but he well this [__]
guy you just telling you I'm not judging
I don't I'm not a referee you know but I
wouldn't have stepped in oh yeah yeah
that's good you're not trying to get on
his dick right Keith Peterson's my
favorite referee dude is that oh the
black guy just let [__] go huh just let
[__] go dude he's white I mean he has
enough neck tats where he [__] oh
yeah that guy [__] little Leprechaun
yeah he's a good oh my God he's a
[__] Legend dude he used to play in a
rock band dude you know his uh his yeah
I best like [__] hardcore white
supremacist music I he's not a white
supremacist I'm saying he looks like one
I wouldn't say that you tell me you
telling me that man does i' whisper it
you know I'm saying dude like that's I'm
joking Keith I love I love all of these
guys I feel like scared talking about
some of this cuz I'm just a huge fan of
the UFC I think all I mean I really
genuinely Ain here you don't got to suck
no one's dick right now I don't feel
like I'm sucking anybody's dick D Jesus
Christ dude guy does one podcast with
Dana next thing you know I love the UFC
it's the best thing ever [__] I
don't think it's the best thing ever but
I'll tell I'll tell you this about it
dude when the when the pandemic happened
the only the UFC kind of became it was
almost like I I I realized this last
night there was a moment
whenever um everybody was standing at
the beginning of the show you know when
the main card starts and the television
show program starts like you can feel
that energy it's like they're playing
the stuff coob don't exist here yeah it
was like but it was the energy of like
it almost was the same energy when
people used to stand and say the Pledge
of Allegiance dude I thought about this
last night I felt like we're all
standing we're all excited we all are
unity yes it felt like a sense of unity
even though there was going to be
battles fought in here tonight and
people were going to agree and disagree
that we were all all unified right and
it reminded me of when I was a kid and
we would do the pledge of Allegiance
dude so and then that made me think that
during the pandemic it became the
[__] the [__] pledge of Alle it
was the only thing that there
was UFC is the last American sport I
mean not a lot of Americans in the sport
but it's like they let us I mean right
they let me say what the [__] I want to
say I mean I literally say women
shouldn't vote because you imagine if I
was NBA they'd [__] kick my ass out
in a heartbeat no more no more byebye go
yeah the you see man Dana here's the
thing I'm not going to [__] jerk off
Dana like this guy you know I would not
and his wife would [__] get mad I
know his son how am I going to shake his
hand after yeah [__] he has a son little
Dana I think well did it just get really
Ambiance here dude huh it's okay no
that's a little bit more romantic now I
feel like Theo Theo's about to get on
the Theo's about to get on the phone and
call one of his scared call girls things
are about to change brother huh they Cas
oh boy I want to know about this though
dude finish off what you're telling me
Sean because I don't even know what it
is we've been jumping bro we've been
jumping oh yeah like me and [__] me and
joean dud we like we're too much in line
you know it's like we're both kind of
Libertarians you know he got a little
bit too hard on the Bernie Sanders
program but you know everybody did I lik
I the all bunch of stuff I loved about
Bernie but like me and me and Rogan dude
like we just got like we're too in line
we're like yeah D we like guns we like
America we like [__] free and it gets
boring after a while then you're like
all right dude well like what do you
want to talk about you want to talk
about a revolution you want to talk
about Freedom like it becomes like this
Echo chamber so I'm getting bored now
and I'm like well let me tell you about
your friend and why he's a you and
Rogan's like whoa whoa wait a minute
like here's the thing I can tell you why
your friend's a or I can keep telling
you about [__] we agree on like I'm just
getting [__] bored here that's a
great Point dude at a certain point even
at Thanksgiving after everybody said the
prayer or whatever everybody said what
they're thankful for somebody needs at
the table needs to call somebody else a
sh [__] I get bored dude I get like
even now you guys's sit here talking
dude like now I'm just trying to make
now I'm just picking on him yeah talking
about you're sucking off Dana you know
like I'm just I'm just try let's say
this you had to go g you had to gay out
or whatever with one good fighter in the
UFC and it can be any weight class I me
talking about physically [__]
somebody no it can be just a date it
could be but there's some kissing at the
end if you and don't pick a little
weight class either no offense to any of
those guys they're Warriors but pick
something [__] don't be a pervert you
know who's it gonna be [__] cuz there's
some handsome guys out there yeah
there's some good looking UFC fighters
oh man am I doing the [__] I'm doing the
[__] right dude what I just told you
you can't there's no guarante I'm going
to see franu if I'm not doing the one
doing the [__] look I just I'm not
trying to die here [__] here you
go hottest UFC fighters of 2023 I better
be on that [__] you better
scroll down we're about to find out
who's number one a [__] Paulo Costa is
number one go back up let's start with
number
one why don't we who's number two you
got a discipline this why you yell at
you got a discipline my jam bro these
[__] have they have no
discipline it's only while we went to
number seven before we even started
counting that's how these people
are you yeah and we got Pao Costa what
do you think one to 10 where would you
take
him I
mean beautiful beautiful guy I mean he's
Gooding
Brazilian dude I don't know if he's been
waxed or not I'm just saying that he
seems like he's a handsome guy I mean I
would think that he would be um I think
that he seems a little bit more like I
think he would take it for sure
you know I mean as like as a Persona I
think that like if KAS is if there's
going to be some [__] he's going to
be the one bent over the the shower you
know it's gonna cost her for saying that
dude I think dude I don't know you're
probably gonna have to fight that guy I
none of this is GNA end well but how
does this so who but who would you take
honestly you got to take one guy in a
nice nice night
out and it's in a nice who in the UFC no
why don't we repas I know we don't want
to [__] because I mean come on now well
yeah I didn't say you're the one who
said it I'm not a gay but um I would do
let me let's say who do I who do I
respect in the UFC who do I admire in
the UFC somebody I
respect and they give me a nice dinner
and the only thing you have to do at the
end say something real nice to
him long hug too but the hug also are
you a hugger dude I don't hug men I
don't hug men the hug can be from the
back that's all I'm saying I don't hug
men the hug can be from the
back [__] a dude yeah [__] this list
I'm now Chandler's handsome too pore's
handsome what about sah gain
I if you get a little step stool to hug
him but maybe no he's French too he's a
nice guy oh alio I don't know about Alo
dude you know good guy he's a good guy
though good gu Evan Williams what about
him Jon Jones no no yeah Jon Jones ain't
a good looking dude I don't know about
that I just don't know I don't want to I
wouldn't go on a date with him no Jon
Jones ain't the one
dude o Thiago Moises huh [__] this I'm
not on this list [__] this list but in
the future you'll be on this list man I
doubt it dude really I doubt it man you
could be a model for something I I mean
I was say you put me at 170 to Su bro
I'm [__] getting all monster jacked
oh dude you could be a model for
something probably 17 what do you think
you'd Model Auto Part look at that guy
that's me oh my god dude this is you
before the dude cuz you had a motor you
had your motorcycle accident you think
after your motorcycle accident you you
became a different guy you think so when
I was
younger I was like a pseudo white
supremacist H yeah right probu believe
that right who would have thought that I
mean I was like the pseudo white
supremacist I'm me talking about like
let's just say like six to like dude a
lot of that yeah we all go through that
we all go through that as a white man
you know yeah anyways so I was like I'll
tell you why I look like in that
photo so I was like dude I mean it was
rough man like I got kicked out of high
school for hate crimes did you really
yeah yeah I didn't graduate high school
I didn't graduate Elementary School who
would have thought right what's your
favorite subject you think I don't
[__] know dude [__] I don't
[__] know man just pick one of them
[__] I didn't go to school dude you were
there I was homeschooled bro really who
was your teacher F I didn't have [__]
Disney Channel bro I watched a lot of
Buzz Light Year bro if you if you're
[__] watching TV at the house that's
not homeschool that's
[__] so sorry I'm being kind of rude
man no you're making fun [__] this guy
dude you're you're the one who's saying
they shouldn't be allowed to even kiss
each
other so anyways there you go and which
what is that back story back no we get
way too off the track here we've never
been on in the train Sean we never so
cam here is that yeah you know she's a
vice president all all due respect you
know yeah but okay so you guys have the
there's a little bit of racism no no no
no so she was uh she was uh something in
California like attorney I know I think
she [__] off some Congressman or
something she was attorney general yeah
she did something what she Nick so
anyways she made a law pass that if kids
miss a certain amount of school the
parents get you know the parents get go
to jail so me in like third grade just
ditching school being a [__] idiot
you know staying home to watch a porn
box
like sorry I'm thinking about the porn
box in it's all right dude so you out of
home you watching the porn box in the
commun
one and then like all of a sudden my mom
gets a call like a letter in the mail
saying hey if Sean does go to school can
go to jail so now she has a choice
homeschool my kid has she had a
full-time job or go to jail damn so my
little mowgly ass you I'm like the
little wild one dude they put my ass
homeschooled I didn't go to school I
didn't read I don't think I learned how
to read until I came an adult you know
really how many words can you type per
minute you think like if can you how
many words can you type per minute [__]
I don't know dude I [__] give me I
mean I remember the T9 days I mean but
so but like on a um I mean I would
probably do well dude I'd do well I do
well anyway how can you type uh I I can
sometimes type without looking on a good
day you know sometimes but anyways I
mean I'm not an educated man like you
this guy's just play dude I wouldn't say
I'm an educated man do you got a degree
huh do you got a degree I have a degree
in urban planning dude what is like an
Associates huh no it's like where to put
medians and [__] if you neighbor Masters
you have Associates what do you got no I
got a degree and what's it like a
master's huh it's a diploma like a like
a a ba what do you got here I got a B uh
yeah what's the first one you get yeah
this [__] Bachelor of stuck
[__] grew up in a moha and he's
panding the dude what do you you have no
idea what you're talking about dude I'm
just fuing with you okay cool so no
continue I'm just [__] with continue D
I'm not the China man I'm not get mad at
you I love that by the way so anyways so
I I was homeschooled I was H School dude
imagine I wasn't socialized bro I was
like a dog that you have to go let
people pet you know like nobody no and
where was this at where were you guys
Empire an inland empire so I go back to
school Ry yeah so I know now I'm like in
seventh grade and myom like we should
probably put this kid back to school
right like [__] worst thing she could
have did did you ever would you and so
you were you had some education at that
point I mean but it's hard I've never
like they Tred to hold me back in
kindergarten like I mean I was like zero
dude like thank God for computers man so
anyways I go to seventh grade and I get
kicked out of school for like a hate
crime so what they do is did you really
do it or not I mean I probably just
called somebody a or dropped the inbomb
like it probably you know it was like
but it's also different time bro it's
different [__] time like racism was
way more common back in like you know 20
years ago yeah so anyways I get put in
the thing where they isolate you they
put you in a a group that they let you
in school like two hours later and they
let you out like two hours early so they
try to keep you from the the
kids so I started ditching again I got
homeschooled again in middle school I
went back into High
School uh ninth grade I got kicked out
of school for a hate crime I think I uh
I don't know I
beat up or something I mean I beat up I
beat up a guy and made I I don't hate
[__] gays yeah no I don't hate
anybody I don't think uh I don't know
there's a couple people that I really
don't [__] like boy but like I had a
lot of like dude I had a lot of [__]
trauma had a lot of anger though you had
a lot of trauma growing up you know I
had this piece of [__] grandfather he
was super racist big white man you know
did he like you at all you think though
no he he did you know he did but like
you know you're a kid with a piece of
[__] father and like you just gravitate
towards anything masculine and like this
is a big old white racist redneck and
I'm angry so next thing I know dude I'm
like right you're just saying racist
[__] you heard at the house yeah yeah
exactly so I get kicked out and then I
started training like ninth like ninth
grade I started training and then dude
like I realized I wasn't a racist I was
just angry I mean I I'll never forget d
I always tell people the first day I
trained I got the [__] kicked out of me
covered in blood bro like first moment
in my life I ever felt happiness first
moment in my [__] life I happened and
[__] kicked out of me just all the anger
the went gone why do you think a lot of
it just comes out when you're cuz I had
a moment where I was uh like I was just
training J Jitsu for a while and there
would be times after the end of class
where I would just kind of start tear
like just so much emotion would come out
of yeah all the anger but I mean again
dude like you know I mean why I got so
mad drous like I went through like
pretty severe trauma as a kid like
pretty [__] up trauma well like I
could sit there and joke about it but I
mean dude I remember like I remember
I've told the story once dude like I was
in probably third fourth grade and [__]
man uh I us always sleep in my mom's
room because I thought my dad was going
to kill my mom so like I would like
sleep by the door I'd sleep to make sure
she was all right yeah sleep I'd sleep
under the bed you know I'd sleep by the
door because I thought my dad was going
to kill my mom so like one day dude is
so [__] up like it was just kind a bad
fight like third fourth grade and I uh
my dad's like [__] that he's not
sleeping he's not sleeping here tonight
he's not like kick him out and so I like
army crawl under the bed and I'm
sleeping under the bed right under the
bed under the I'm like laying on the bed
like just laying underneath the bed like
as they're fighting because I think my
dad's going to kill my mom wow he was
that violent he's just coward you know
so anyways like I remember we had like
dogs you know we white trash and the
house was like flea infested you have a
dog in there with you no no dog was
there with me but I remember laying
under the
bed and like fleas were just like
jumping all over me you know I'm like I
think they might be like a dildo next to
me I [__] you not dude oh
manck we got this kind of like orange
looking carpet so picture like me like
third fourth grade yeah laying under a
bed fleas jumping all over me there's a
[__] like dildo next to
me yeah sounds like a Japanese game show
who puts a dildo underneath the bed but
it's not sanitary put it like put it in
your [__] drawer yeah at least put it
in a drawer that has a bunch of gum and
coins in it yeah under the bear with the
flee yeah dude that's scary so anyways
my dad gets on top of my mom she says
like I remember he said like I'm going
to [__] I'm going to kill you I'm
going to [__] kill you tonight guess
maybe it's just rough sex we don't know
at this moment right and you were under
the bed I'm under the bed so he starts
strangling her and I get out and the
only thing I can see is a guitar I just
[__] crack him in the head call the
cops and then he gives a I run down the
street calls the cop gets AR rest my
dumb ass mom ba him out of jail oh but
it's like I mean even that like I mean
that was like I wouldn't even say that's
tip of the iceberg I remember like being
a little kid so I would always miss
school because my dad would get home
drunk start drinking at like 6 he would
get home at like
7 and and like just be up until like 3:
in the morning just like tell myom tell
drinking tell my mom she's a [__] to
kill her like and I remember I used to
like what a loser huh sorry to say that
about your dadie [__] died of cancer but
anyways he's on a cancer yeah yeah he
died of cancer yeah [__] you know
proba the hate inside of him build I
hate to say that he was just drugs he
lot lots of drugs pain pills why I don't
do drugs so I remember like I used to
sit there and just kind of like hug my
mom's leg in the in the kitchen you know
like we had this little Nook and she
would like go in the nook and I would
just sit there like all night long I'm
by like the feet of my mom and my dad
like I'm gonna [__] kill you and this
and that and I'll never forget like he
would talk about like like burn her face
with acid and mind you I'm in elementary
school
I'm I'm school right so like so that's a
lot of responsibility than you feel
probably just to like take care of your
mom oh yeah yeah now he'd always tell
her that like if you cheat on me and she
probably was cheating on him if you
cheat on me I'm gonna like cut you up
and put you in a bottle of acid and bury
you so now you fast forward this like I
don't go to school I'm up till 3: in the
morning you know I couldn't stay awake
in school like so like I remember I was
like in third grade no second grade and
I kept falling asleep in my desk my
teacher took my desk away from me and
she made me like like stand up and so me
I'm like [__] you being this little kid
I just went and fell asleep on the
ground and mind you like the school
system's like oh Sean like he's just a
bad kid they don't realize I'm up till 3
o'clock in the morning like you know
late I mean [__] dude I remember it's
hard to stay up late and learn dude I
remember like laying in bed like I
remember when I stop believing in God
man like [__] like I had [__] um
yeah it's crazy [__]
dude crazy [__] man yeah it's okay man
it's a lot of that sad dude I used to be
scared at night like uh I used to stand
up like I heard when I was a kid that
like if you peed around your like
animals could pee somewhere that other
animals wouldn't come you know what I'm
talking about you know what I'm talking
about huh yeah have you ever heard
that yeah I'm sorry
bud so
man I'm sorry buddy that's all good
[Music]
we don't have talk man I can just sit
here with you for a
minute oh
[__] [__] six
second I can just sit here we can just
sit here it's all good you're six second
I just process
it
I
think it's one hard things that people
don't understand like trauma you know
yeah unless it just comes out oh no dude
like I
remember I have a hole in my gum
yeah when I was a kid I used to scratch
my gum and have a hole in my gum you
know just from being nervous and stuff n
just anxiety you
know yeah even to this day yeah I mean
the day dude like I'm a grown ass man I
don't give a [__] I mean you could post
this I don't care oh dude I don't have
any no it's all good dude I mean it's is
what it is dude like it is what it is
like people understand like when I talk
about like go i' kill a man it's like
you don't understand you're like when
you go through that level of trauma like
you just view the world differently you
know so it's like I have a hole in my
gum because I'd have so much anxiety as
a kid I would just scratch my gum and
tell like I mean just blood you know and
you know you're like you're in
pre-elementary school you don't know why
you're doing it yeah yeah [__] a I I
remember like like suicide you know like
you don't even know what suicide is when
you're a kid when you're really talking
about suicide like being a little kid
like laying in bed like just like man
I'm just [__] I'm done with this [__]
you know like there can't be a god it
makes me sad [__] up dude no it just
makes me sad that a kid has to feel that
way you know yeah so like any kid
whenever drus goes on there and like he
jokes about that [__] right like dude
you have no idea yeah I mean and this is
like as a comedian you got to joke about
trauma like people think like I joke
like I joke about all this [__] like you
know I were're laughing like you got to
joke about like you got to joke about it
if you don't like how do you process
that you know how do you how do you
process that kind of abuse I mean I'll
never forget my
brother my brother we were like upstairs
once and he taped and he taped knives to
his [__] leg I mean we're talking
elementary school he was going to go sit
on the couch with my dad and stab him
dude like you know it's
like
that's like that level of [__] you know
yeah mix account with a killer man but
yeah yeah you [__] I mean we all
we've all gone through
[__] your brother a pretty nice guy yeah
he's all right you know he's a close
friend
yeah it's like it just gives you like
[__] you can't yeah you can't [__]
deal with
yeah man Life's good I make a lot of
money now I'm happy but you know did you
think like cuz yeah I remember being so
scared when I was a kid like I was
saying like I remember hearing that like
animals if you pee like animals if
animal peed another animal wouldn't come
so I would stand up on my bed at night
and I would pee around my bed in a
circle because I was afraid that things
were going to get me no [__] who were
you afraid like any particular just
everything everything I mean I was just
afraid of everything I mean you you
didn't really grow up with a dad you
know like I understand yeah I just
should have anybody just teach me about
anything I was just like an I was just
felt like
a I don't know I think I felt worthless
probably yeah but then I think not
having a dad's rough dude like I mean
you had a dad but like yeah but I think
not having somebody like communicate
with you or [__] treat you I don't
know I don't know what it was but I was
just really scared yeah that's why I
think when I see a lot of you guys like
I think there's a lot of guys out there
who [__] I wish I could have been even
able to defend myself in my neighborhood
or anything like I didn't have anybody
look out I you know I just didn't so I
think you know you see guys Fu man like
you guys it's like at least you know
even though you're fighting each other
it's still like well you got to learn it
you got to want to be violent some I
mean there's some guys like you know
there's some guys like Jon Jones who's
just a he's a [__] athlete you know
he's just like there's some there's a
lot of athletes and there's guys like me
who were like if it wasn't for fighting
bro I would be jail I'd be in jail like
it it's not like like to have like you
don't understand like I I truly have a
deep down urge to kill somebody like I
can't it doesn't go away like I just
like I don't know what it is man like
you know you just think like yeah it's
[__] up dude you know so like when I
train it gives me tools to process it
but like there there's definitely
something inside me that like tells me
that like the moment I take someone's
life and now why you we could probably
agree that it's because you have so much
Tri when you're victimized that like
that's your way of like protecting you
and saying that if you go and kill
somebody like you'll be happy and I
would like I would if you could let me
kill a man like happy as I can't but
right some places some places right but
you know pull up in
Memphis do what you want but see I don't
know like a lot of times I don't know
what it's like to to talk to normal
people yeah I have some people who know
exactly what it's like who've been
molested who've been abused you know and
it's like I have some people know you
know been beat up these people know what
it's like but you go talk to the average
person like man you just don't know it's
like some people do but you don't know
what it's like to be able to like the
only thing like that would make me happy
is the [__] literally cave in your
[__] skull and like the only thing
that would I truly want is the [__]
like make somebody hurt [__] hurt yes
you know and then the problem is like it
makes me Vol it makes me volatile so I
don't really even this day like I don't
go out much trust yourself probably I
can't trust
myself because I want to it's not like
it's not like I get angry and like when
I want to attack Dr I wasn't angry when
I went in joyful oh I I want I was more
than happy some seemed like a Christmas
attack like that's the only thing that
made me happy I'm like I remember
sitting there like as like I mean cuz
once I [__] he started tackling me I
started dropping like these 12:00 elbows
you will get a senal
feeling yeah well that was so [__] up
too and I'm so happy they didn't get it
from a right
angle I bit him uh-uh I [__] you not so
I whenever he went into me and I
remember like at that moment like you
you'll watch he's handsome yeah now he's
a good looking dude so this moment he
tackles me watching you'll
see right there I start thinking you see
my head goes up towards it I started
thinking like how could I hurt this man
I'm gonna take a [__] chunk at I'm
going to bite his [__] ear off yeah
and he goes in the day and then I
remember like telling myself at that
moment like Sean you can't do that
that's something you can't walk away
from like if you do that right you're
going over another line if I go that
then I'm going to jail then I'm going
cannibal then I'm F cannibal you don't
want to be that like look Sean we'll
accept certain things here okay you know
so like whenever you like that's scary
because you don't know like that line
must be so I just don't leave I don't
leave my house dude it's too risky too
risky and and most people I meet are
[__] great most people I meet are
great they ask for a picture but like it
only takes one guy to be like hey you
know what [__] you you piece of [__]
yeah and next thing you knew I'm [__]
on I'm caving his head on the school on
the ground damn it reminds me like when
people like my sister they have like
pitbulls and you see people 100% that
yeah I hate to say that it's not fair to
no is what it is dude it's like a dog
bro it's like well it's an animal I
wouldn't say a dog yeah but it's like
but it's like something that can't
always probably trust its own I don't
know and the problem is it feels good
it's not like [__] it's like I don't
know everyone's like oh I get blacked
out angry like I'm not angry like I'm
like I'm a i me I'm almost like this an
euphoric like it's a bliss it's like
a it's like yeah just it's it's peaceful
you know yeah man but I'm I'm better
dude like you know MMA helps like I
always tell guys like I used to think
guys with PTSD were the biggest [__]
you know like I'm like PTSD like what
what you can't leave your house you
can't have relationships oh you have got
climing PTSD from like getting because
there's new speed bumps in their
neighborhood but you know what I would
say to that though it's like and I have
so much more sympathy for like guys who
suffer from that because you got to
understand I was born in it like like I
was born in the life I was born like I
mean I remember I stopped believing in
God when I was in elementary school I
was laying in bed crying thinking about
killing myself yeah like there can't be
a [__] God here how's there a god
like like why would I be in this
situation if there's a God ain't no
[__] god it's heartbreaking to think
that a child would have to have those
thoughts and I mean yeah my earliest
memories dude like I don't have like
when I think back in like when I think
of a kid I cannot cannot recall one good
memory not one [__] good memory as a
kid so you cannot pay me to relive my
life can [__] pay me now it's fine
yeah but when I used like with PTSD I
used to like look at like soldiers
coming home like you guys are [__]
yeah like what the [__] wrong with you
and then you realize like I grew up in
the life I grew up in it I learned how
to cope and how to deal I learned that
don't go out in public hide away from
people like don't go do these things but
I couldn't picture being like a
20 like I couldn't picture being 24
years old and being a normal guy like I
I like life I like chicks I like going
to party I like drinking and all of a
sudden like the curtain drops and you're
like who the [__] am I I can't I'm I'm
volatile I can't go out like it's rough
man [__] that's why training I always
tell people like saved your life oh fck
not in my life and this what people like
I wouldn't be a mass probably saved the
life of about 20 just random strangers
in the street too I mean I used to walk
I remember a kid dude I used to walk in
bad neighborhoods with a knife just like
just waiting like people always like I
wouldn't be a serial killer like I'm not
a I'm not a high function psychopath
like that's not what you got to be so
organized I think to do that so what
would have happened is I would have been
another statistic I would have been
walking down the street some guy would
have uh some guy would I would have
killed him I would have been in jail and
i' been then I would probably been a
white supremacist and that's my life you
now I'll never forget I was driving I
got arrested when I was younger
obviously who the [__] thought right
yeah I knew it two two yeah two gbi two
F GB and and I was driving back from
Court and [__] I was on a
motorcycle and this guy
like this guy I'm just I want to hurt
some I'm angry I'm pissed off I'm
looking at [__] hard prison time I'm
just
angry he's on a motorcycle and I I guess
I kind I cut him off like I I
manipulated the situation I manipulated
the situation because I wanted to
[__] hurt somebody and he pulls over
and I get off my bike and I'm literally
like in this moment like I'm gonna
[__] kill this man and then the
moment I get off my bike he pulls out a
badge and like he's a cop I'm like oh
[__] and I remember the guy like the guy
was generally concerned like hey man
like are you okay like the [__] wrong
with you you know because he knew like
he knew yeah that's crazy there was a
point in my life too where like I didn't
I must have been grateful then that he
did that almost in a way oh yeah I mean
if he didn't like who knows what
happened I remember there was one point
in my life dude where like I was just
going through
it I was in the UFC too at the time and
I was just like I Liv in tacul and there
was like a big like motorcycle gang
population like I Vos or some
[__] and I remember like just was like D
I lay in bed and like I was hurting dude
like not like I don't know if it's
depressed but it's like well your body's
not supposed to is a kid you're not
supposed to have that much pain inside
of so no this is like my 20s now I
remember 20s and like I just like it get
it gets you build up so much we like I
need I I have to do something like I
need to hurt somebody to make this go
away and I I never forget didn't happen
but there was like I was Ding and
there's a Vago I'm like this is the one
this is what's a Vago like a gang banger
like a
more
carh I was like this is the like I was
like this is my Victim like this is my
crime that like if I can't get away with
it he's a gang banger he'll accept it
like I could kill this man somewhere if
there's not a
camera and there's a chance that we
don't get away and I remember like I'll
never forget I went in front of him and
that day and I like [__] boom cut him
off and flipped him I said [__] you and
then I was like waiting for him to like
follow me somewhere and I even had it
planned out I was like I'm in the UFC
UFC I was going to take him to the you
already in the UFC yeah inaca and take
him to like a dirt road and just [__]
kill him beat him death you Aaron you
like Aaron Hernandez just beat him to
death and then you know it's exciting
it's scary at the same time you're
thinking about doing it and then he just
like I guess he just didn't want it he
just drove away flipped me off drove
away but all it took like all it took
was all it would have taken was one
other little him like all right [__] you
I'm gonna follow you [__] D next thing
you know dude I'm [__] I'm gonna be
in prison handcuffed right cuz you know
you're so angry you don't think about
consequences you just think about like
I'm hurting so so much like there's so
much pressure in me like I got to get
this go I got to make it go away yeah it
just man it's [__] crazy that
uh it just it's so unfair
that how much pressure
like sometimes people have to have in
them for [__] they didn't even do yeah
you know well it's because your brain
you know it's like your brain tells you
that this cave is bad don't go there
it's like an evolutionary like yeah like
so and and one of the hardest things for
me it's like
I was brought up in a world that doesn't
exist so like I was brought up in this
like primitive Primal [__] up world
where like my brain was telling me that
you are in a very bad place and the
world's
bad right so it it my brain evolved to
be violent it involved to be violent
hypersexual
aggressive and then as a man now I'm in
2023 how do I function yeah like I got
to go through I got to go through the
world as like I this is not what my
brain was evolved for wow so I was
that's what training helps you're almost
like a time traveler it must feel like
in a way well cuz I I involve like CU
like my brain evolved in a very
primitive way like it evolved in like
yeah like you got to kill this man you
got to [__] that girl like there was a
communal porn box
like it's not fair yeah but it is what
it is but it is what it is right right
you can't always keep looking back at it
because you just move on and right now
I'm happy bro I mean you're happy your
Life's good you mean you went through
some sh we've all been through some [__]
like if you look at the statistics of
child abuse we've all been through some
[__] some people more than others [__]
my life was [__] Disneyland some
people I know I mean I'm just working
like as
like as I get older I just stay away
from people do you think it's gotten
better or worse over
time
uh it definitely better like my mental
state of mind like dude having a
girlfriend helps yeah I know you said
that you really and slap you're like
yeah I really like having this so it's
like dude whenever she's
gone like and mind you I like I could go
[__] anybody I want to [__] I don't yeah
but like whenever she's gone dude like
I'll just be in my house and I start
looking at all the things I own like I
have a couch a [__] TV like why do I
have this [__] I don't want this [__]
and you start like and you start just
getting like crazy yeah I don't do I
don't do well alone yeah and that's what
that's one of those things too where
like a lot of people with trauma you
self-isolate yourself because it feels
good right you want to be alone like and
you want to keep yourself away from
people a lot of times like I want if I'm
angry or whatever is going on with me
the last thing I want to do so now is
just put it around anybody else yeah
like exactly you not you want to like
you want to be most like like all these
Mass Shooters all these killers like you
want to be alone like you want to be
quiet you don't people make you feel
outcasted they don't make you feel right
and so what you do is you listen to
those thoughts and you stay
alone and then you just and and the
moment you go out say I'll be at loan
I'll be Al loone I'll go get food like
no Sean get out of the house go get food
like right do something cuz it helps but
but it doesn't help but it doesn't if
it's you because you have so much of
that [__] risk potential I have that
part now I'm at in and out and I'm
looking at all these [__] people and
I'm just like anger is just Building
inside me I'm getting [__] angrier so
my My Girl My Girls helped me a lot
function function yeah she's help me a
lot dude do you have like a some fun
memories from when you were a kid like
was there something fun that you guys
used to go do like did you go trick or
reading or something like that my
brother I mean [__] my brother was
like my dad was he really like but my
brother was [__] brutal to me like
you know you my brother's 3 years older
than me and you're having a he was like
my dad you're having a him raise me as a
kid and all he knows is stff [__] he's
seen or learned oh yeah so my mom he'd
[__] me up beat the [__] out of me like
I get I remember I'd get every day my
mom would come back from work I'd be
[__] up with bruises I bet he feels
horrible about it uh I mean it's kind of
hard dude because it's like you're a kid
raising a kid
right you know right it's almost not
even fair for him to feel horrible about
it yeah you know so it's like I mean I
remember we had a [__] prison whip
bro my dad had a prison Whip and my
brother would be like [__] if you
don't clean the house I'm G whack you
with this thing you may hit with a
[__] prison whip dude it [__]
takes skin off the bone I mean it takes
[__] skin off but I wouldn't like it
it's not good dude it's a big metal FP
plastic whip so you take my dad then you
take my brother just you know like yeah
adds up dude
and it's scary to think man there so
many people go through so much [__] like
that it's plastic bro the the prison
whip is plastic you got to go type in
prison that's an expensive modern prison
whip modern prison whip yeah this
[__] is looking at like the
1500s and [__] over here n it's it's a
hard plastic rod bro yeah it's kind of
like that but like that's new age that's
some prison [__] that's a new age [__]
but yeah man it's been a good podcast
Ste good [__] dude well I'm trying to
think if there's anything else that we
can talk about that makes me now one a
little bit less depressed well I just
think no I think just like when you talk
about that kind of stuff like I do
realize like when I'm able to share
things like cuz some people that's the
one of the gifts that some people have
right and I believe this is
like you know people that went through
something that was super really tough
right and they're able to get through it
and then if they are able to
articulate what it was like and how it
affected them if they were to do all
that and get through it and still have
some way to articulate
well that's where it's able to be
beneficial the the difficult thing with
me it's like with
fighting
like I was able to get [__] I was able
to like be with women and have that but
most big women too I bet big women big
women big women but but guys the problem
is like a lot of guys like me that's not
necessarily the case they don't train
they don't fight and they just
self-isolate you just got to like yeah
man it's hard just what I would tell
anybody is just don't self-isolate even
though know it feels good and you want
to [__] you know feels good like I
just don't do it yeah I'll do it I yeah
yeah cuz I I'll like go against that's
why I go to like recovery meetings and
stuff because it makes me go to a
meeting I have to be in a room where
people like like one thing I like about
recovery meetings is like you're able to
share how you feel in there about [__]
and nobody can cross talk so you
recovery meetings yeah does it help oh
it helps a lot yeah it helps a lot bro
it's a lot of people talking about all
this kind of [__] well addiction
addiction's real like um
yeah addiction I mean like [__] man I
mean we all got addictions you know mine
a lot was women you know prior of my
girl like I had a bad like sex addiction
not sex addiction but it's like just
like all guys like you know you're a
single guy the only thing that makes you
feel good is chasing a woman oh yeah you
know oh when I was young dude like once
I learned about jerking off and
everything oh that's bad all down here
all bad all bad if I had a thought an
idea anything I would just jerk I
actually get a lot I had a good idea I'd
go jerk off like know it's funny I'll
watch porn and the moment I come dude I
get kind of pissed off yeah but like
it's kind of weird like so my dad right
my dad hypersexual dildo communal porn
box that like I feel a lot of Shame from
sex so like you know like I like I'll
watch porn like f jerk I don't really
watch porn Much Anymore the second I
jerk off I feel so ashamed of myself I
feel so ashamed but I grew up my D yell
at my dick I'll call you're just mad you
went for that you went for that
temporary fiction yeah yeah but you know
what it's the only way I knew to make
myself feel good was that was the only
good feeling I had in my [__] whole
life was just like that so I was like
it's it's it's a chemical dope you just
should chasing it but you know like I
mean dude I'm like I'll get on a
motorcycle and I mean last night going
to the event dude my manager is with me
and I'm driving like 120 through red
lights on the back n he he has another
bike but he like he didn't keep up right
I even told him I was like you don't
don't keep up with me like just stay at
home like you just I'll meet you at the
event we're going the same play I'm
going like 120 through red lights and
it's just like that even though like
yeah you can't but it just feels good it
makes feel good that like temporary high
of feeling good you know yeah yeah
exactly it feels good yeah but you know
I mean I guess we' wrap this
[__] up it's getting late I it's
getting late but I would tell I would
just tell you guys that train you know
don't
isolate [__] man good luck I wish you
guys the best of luck I believe that
[__] man we're [__] huh yeah we're
[__] don't have kids you know just don't
[__] I I know I actually funny we'd
actually probably be really good parents
yeah but you when you get so much trauma
you're like I don't really know you know
yeah I know it is a little risky dude
there's days where I'm like I'd be a
great dad and there's days like I would
leave those
[__] one long afternoon and I'm
[__] to get some milk brother like damn
that milk's far away that's what my
son's going to be thinking but [__] man
you know at the end of the day guys we
all know that I'm a little [__] up the
little [__] up we're all little [__]
up [__] oh we're all [__] up dude
wish you guys the best man and you know
what I tell you guys if if you ever have
those like [__] that feelings come train
Jiu-Jitsu MMA it's like it's a
Brotherhood there you'll have a lot of
people that are like-minded not I mean I
train with a lot of normal guys where
there are a lot of guys who have been
molested by [__] you know I know guys
I've trained with guys who' have been
molested you know it's like yeah yeah so
it's like if you're a if you're a guy
going through some rough [__] you know a
gym is a good home for you or just go to
a [__] meeting yeah but a Jim there
is something physical about it
physically getting things out of your
body is really interesting because I
think there's different ways to do it
yeah you know I think you can do it
physically I think you can do it by
going to like like therapy and stuff
like that iasa was super helpful you
ever do that no I've I've never I do
drug scare me dude yeah this is
different though I wouldn't never push a
drug on anybody this is this isn't
something you could go do in an alley or
before you go the problem is you like I
know like my inner thoughts I know what
I want yeah and it's like
I don't want to put myself in a position
to where like yeah that's true let's
keep you chill yeah you know let's keep
you on imagine like imagine if like I do
some like I do something I I is
different but if I do like if I start
drinking alcohol yeah that's
bad then like that that wall that I put
up in my brain is going to start like
coming down a little bit coming down I
just stay away from that [__] yeah but I
mean know [__] you know helps from
what they
say man what do we know yeah what do we
know dude we're just a couple [__]
idiots talking crying and [__] on
[__] uh dude you just beat up one of
your [__] co-workers yesterday yeah
[__] man [__] deserved it yeah the
only thing the only thing that I will
say about dra is is you're very lucky
that happened in a fight and not and out
in the world because God bless the UFC
then huh God bless the
UFC Sean thanks man yeah man I
appreciate it dude happy holidays you
guys
[__] oh yeah dude
all right my bad dude you the man dude I
appreciate
you good
times on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to take
little